I think porn has really changed the game, you know,
out of the gate now sex as much kinkier, I think, as a porn out of the gate,
now it's like choking, spitting finger up the butt, which is weird.
Cause these are all things my older brother did to torment me.
It's all the same. We've just taken bullying out of the playground.
Brought in the bedroom. I got my girl on top. Now I'm like Indian sunburn.
Ah, seriously, you go to a school yard during recess.
Some kids holding a girl down and pulling her hair, calling her names. I'm like,
man, he's good. I'm taking notes to get back to your girl. She was like,
wow, where'd you learn that? I'm like a couple of third graders actually,
but don't worry. I like.
[Inaudible].